it was you said san quentin and that's
the prison where you were
the boxing champion of the whole prison
yeah the sam clinton boxing champion in
soledad i was try facility champion uh
that was all three because solidarity
has three penitentiaries central south
uh and and north and uh
yeah i was try a facility champion so
that was kind of cool can you help me
understand what uh the boxing
organization
of of uh san quentin or solid dad
prisons looks like do they have like are
there refs like there's a ring like
no they had scheduled fight we'd have
like fights with the the
the army and the navy would come in
sometimes we uh
we
do they would be exhibitions you know
but the only problem is that damn
mexicans don't understand the exhibition
you know they'll come up we got money on
your home no wait it's an exhibition no
hey don't [ __ ] we got money homes and
so you either had to tell the guy that
you were fighting look homes
go for what you know you know or
surprise him you know i mean if he
looked up and surprised him and uh
but we had some great fights we had some
great fights up there they took all the
all the athletics out of prison fight
you know they they don't have no more
now it's now it's just a a warehouse for
insanity you know
it took all the weights out
i don't know
really you can't work out in prison
anymore well they got bars you just you
do chit-ups and stuff so right um so so
every boxing match was an exhibition
about in in the prison no
no the bouts
with with inmates
were fights
i think that was the beginning of like
the tough man con remember the tough man
contest that they used to have where a
guy 145 pounds might
fight a guy 180 yeah well that's kind of
where prison fights were
you
you never knew who you were fighting
wow okay so so and it was like full like
boxing gloves like tape tape up the
hands and in the ring with the ref
how do you train do you just fight other
guys on the off time and you know you
had a sparring spa i when i stopped
boxing i never thought i always fought
but uh i had trained
five
fighters and all of them won champions
and and uh
uh i would spar like five rounds with
each of them you know every day or every
other day or whenever because that's the
way people
people do time all kinds of ways you
play chess you read you play handball
you become baseball football
at the time that i was there right or
you box and you just box
you know that's
i was such a great shape you know you
were like a vitamin peel but now
like like i said it's just a warehouse
for insanity you're just
doing time
man um and you were able to because you
were the boxing champion that was how
you were able to not ever have to join
any prison gangs yeah well
i got out in 1969
1972 was when the mafia really came into
power you know and that's when 1971
that's when 69 is when they started
be coming up you know coming coming
coming now they're in power but
the mexican mafia wasn't
as big as it was so you know now it's
it's a force to be reckoned with if you
go to prison
now you got a good permission out here
to kill somebody
crazy yeah were you ever in san quentin
with any celebrities
yeah danny drew
can i just tell you how [ __ ] up my new
tour is it's completely multimedia
legitimately x-rated there's legal
waivers all over the venue because i'm
actually worried about getting sued and
i don't give a [ __ ] man because it's
gnarly and it's all the stuff i wasn't
allowed to do on jackass so get to my
[ __ ] website stevo.com and get your
tickets man especially with this movie
coming out dude they're all gonna sell
dude so hurry up while you can get seats